[Musique]
il représente 60 % du budget des
étudiants c'est le premier poste de
dépenses des jeunes et ils pèsent donc
très lourd aujourd'hui dans leur
précarité qu'ils soient jeunes actifs ou
étud ud cet ennemi numéro 1 des jeunes
c'est le logement la crise de ce secteur
est général c'est une dépense qui est
difficile à assumer pour beaucoup de
monde mais dans avoir 20 ans cette
semaine vous allez comprendre que pour
les jeunes c'est encore plus compliqué
comment expliquer cette crise
particulièrement aigue pour cette
génération surtout quelle solution
envisager car être correctement logé
c'est une condition essentielle pour
réussir ses étude pour réussir son
entrée dans la victive pour réussir
enfin à accéder à l'autonomie alors sur
ce plateau pour pour en parler
j'accueille deux expertes du sujet j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir Gena elgo
bonjour bonjour vous êtes directrice
générale de l'opsoco l'opsoco
l'Observatoire société et consommation
également sur ce plateau Ingrid napi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes économiste de
l'immobilier professeur à l'École de
pont Paritech et directrice de recherche
à l'Institut Louis Bachelier et sur ce
plateau nous sommes aussi avec deux
jeunes c'est le principe de cette
émission avec nous Antoine Boussard
bonjour bonjour vous avez 28 ans vous
êtes juriste et vous êtes le fondateur
de l'association bye bye pour brigade
associative interlocataire et donc c'est
une association récente qui a quelques
mois qui se bat pour faire respecter
l'encadrement des loyers dans les
grandes métropoles c'est ça c'est bien
ça et également avec nous sur ce plateau
Mael Bou bonjour bonjour vous êtes
étudiante à Sciences Po vous avez 21 ans
vous êtes actuellement en césure et vous
travaillez d'ailleurs comme stagiaire
dans les médias mais vous êtes aussi
créatrice de contenu on vous connaît
notamment pour une vidéo qui a été vu
l'an dernier 10 millions de fois on en
regarde un
extrait 4 ans je rentre en ma 4e année
d'étude et ça fait 4 ans que chaque
année il diminue ma bourse en première
année je pouvais vivre juste avec ma
bourse et cétait vraiment super sachant
que mes parents peuvent pas du tout
payer mes études genre ils ont pas les
moyens la deuxème année ils m'ont coupé
ma bourse de moitié donc j'ai dû
travailler ensuite je suis arrivée à
Berlin et genre je devais vraiment
travailler 20h par semaine en plus de
mes études qui étaient aussi genre 15
20h c'était juste énorme bon la première
chose qu'on a envie de savoir Maë avant
de parler du fond de l'émission C'est un
peu comment ça va quand même depuis
depuis cette vidéo ça va mieux euh
malheureusement pas grâce à la bourse
mais ça va mieux parce que je continue à
travailler mais j'ai trouvé un travail
qui correspond à mes études donc c'est
ça en plus de votre stage ou bien à
votre stage grâce oui à côté de mon
stage ou cette vidéo on l'a vu je disais
elle a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
elle a fait de vous l'un des des
symboles de la précarité
étudiante moi ce qui m'interpelle aussi
c'est de voir ben les conséquences que
que ça c'est problèmes financiers c'est
psychologique ça envahit absolument tout
votre quotidien ça ça remplit enfin
c'est partout c'est tout le temps parce
que je pense que quand on a pas d'argent
en fait ça impacte à pe près tous les
aspects de la vie quotidienne c'est une
énorme charge mentale et ouais ça m'a
enfin ça m'a fait plein de problèmes
aussi bien bah santé mentale que santé
physique voilà quand on a pas d'argent
tout est compliqué Antoine vous vous
reconnaissez dans le cri d'alarme poussé
par Mael est-ce que le le type de
personne que vous aidez aujourd'hui
correspondre à ce type de de difficulté
financière ah oui bah c'est ce qu'on
constate à Lyon notamment que notre
association elle est pour l'instant
vraiment basée à Lyon mais au vu de la
demande qu'on a à Paris on constate que
les loyers sont effectivement beaucoup
trop chers il respectent pas l'encement
des loyers on y reviendra je pense par
la suite et donc oui la situation on en
a cotidiennement des dossiers commeelle
aujourd'hui alors on va effectivement
parler du logement dans cette émission
parce que trouver un logement correct
quand on est jeune qu'on soit étudiant
ou jeune actif c'est souvent la galère
surtout dans les grandes villes comme
Paris ou Lyon comme vous le dites et
quand on n pas toutes les garanties
demandées c'est quasi mission impossible
c'est ce qu'on constatait Adrien pin et
Pompeo copola regardez 3h du mat 2h du
mat 1 heure du mat je suis assis pendant
que les gens il d je me dis pendant ce
moment peut-être qu'il y a des logements
ouz je suis toujours les demain de
logement des dizaines d'onglets ouverts
en Contin continu pour candidater à des
annonces et pour l'instant que des refus
à 23 ans no vit dans un foyer à Paris
depuis bientôt 2 ans et doit partir dans
6 mois il n'a pas les moyens de louer
dans le parc privé si j'ai pas vraiment
eu de logement je risque de me retrouver
à la rue et je sais pas où aller et
aujourd'hui je suis plus étudiant j'ai
un contrat CDI donc moi actuellement mon
espoir c'est seulement que la mairie
puisse m'aider depuis plusieurs mois il
envoie des mail et des courriers à la
mairie voilà voilà le premier en juin
dans une lettre l'adjoint au logement
lui a conseillé quelques sites internet
nouveau y a candidaté mais toujours sans
succès ma demande n'a jamais été retenue
un cas loin d'être isolé dans ce comité
local des de logement pour les moins de
30 ans les rendez-vous se succèdent
chaque après-midi bonjour bonjour pour
certains la crainte de ne pas avoir un
logement stable et même devenu réalité
constituer un dossier est alors une
épopée administrative dit que c'était
quoi votre situation au niveau du
logement là en ce moment je le trouve
séusement ouais et vous êtes hébergé de
gauche à droite ouite vous essayer de
trouver foyer ou bien colocation mais
pas parce que c'est c'est un peu
compliqué des conseillers comme Laura
leur montre des solutions temporaires et
des aides financières parfois peu
connues que ce soit appel ou ou d'autres
aides auquel ils peuvent prétendre il y
en a beaucoup qui sont pas assez
renseignés lanceussi avec eux les
candidatures pour des foyers de jeunes
travailleurs ou des résidences sociales
il y en a beaucoup qui entendent parler
des faê jeunes travailleurs mais qui
savent pas vraiment ce que c'est ils
sont pas posé la question et quand nous
appelle ils charerge plutôt un
appartement dans le privé ou un logement
social certains étudiants ont perdu leur
place en résidence universitaire voire
en ont été expulsés dans les cas les
plus extrêmes un risque accru en période
de rentrée ça j'en ai eu pas mal aussi
des jeunes expulsés du cru dans la
période un peu il savent pas trop de
stabilisation bah c'est vraiment à ce
momentl que c'est le plus compliqué avec
des étudiants de l'université parien
Pauline portefé chargée d'études à la
Fondation abépierre a publié en
septembre une enquête sur les expulsions
du cru une autre étudiante qu'on a
rencontré au cours de de l'enquête j'ai
contacté toutes les associations
possibles j'ai craqué j'étais seule
isolé sans famille je viens de l'aide
social à l'enfance j'avais moins de 150
€ par mois pour vivre le juge
administratif il donne un maximum de 15
jours de délai avant de partir on a
rencontrer des étudiants notamment un
étudiant qui a été expulsé l'année
dernière au milieu du mois de novembre
parce qu'il avait
hébergé un camarade dans sa chambre ce
système là de de de contrat extrêmement
précaire il est surtout lié à la
peignuriie de logement s'il y avait plus
de logement on pourrait penser que il y
aurait plus de délais qui seraiit
accordés d'après l'Union étudiante le
nombre de logements du cru augmente plus
lentement que le nombre d'étudiants en
2023 le syndicat compte seulement un
appartement en cité universitaire pour
17 étudiants Maë au cours de votre
scolarité vous avez habité dans
différentes villes vous vous avez habité
à Nancy à Paris à Berlin est-ce que le
logement ça a toujours été un problème
un problème important alors moi mes
études ont commencé je viens de
Montpellier donc j'ai j'ai dit à mes
parents que moi je voulais pas rester
puce qu'il y avait pas les études que je
voulais à Montpellier et tout de suite
ils m'ont dit d'accord mais il faut que
tu trouves un moyen de payer parce que
nous en fait on peut pas te donner
d'argent pour un loyer on peut garder à
la maison on peut pas te payer un loyer
donc tout de suite ça a été il faut que
je me débrouille pour me pour financer
vous aviez ça en tête dès que vous avez
comment moi dans le supérieur bah même
quand j'ai fait mes vœux en fait sur
parcoursu je me suis dit que par exemple
Paris je l'ai jamais trop envisagé comme
endroit parce que je savais que je
pourrais pas payé c'était pas possible
donc non si c'est pour ça que c'était
bien au début parce que c'est pas très
cher le c'est pas saturé en fait comme
ville d'cord parce que vous êtes
étudiante à Sciences Po Paris avec le
campus délocalisé de Nanci ouis donc ça
c'était vraiment en fait je me suis
rendu compte de ce que c'est aussi les
petites villes et le fait que en fait
faire ses études avec un petit loyer
c'est vraiment un privilège et puis
après je suis allée à Berlin où j'ai 6
mois avant déjà commencer à chercher un
logement un travail pareil pour financer
le logement donc ça a toujours été une
énorme préoccupation j'avais une toute
petite chambre de 10 m² bon c'est pas
c'est très bien et c'est audessus ça
vous suffisait mais c'est oui voilà
c'était dans une colocation en fait
c'était c'était pas optimal mais c'était
déjà bien et là à Paris par contre c'est
j'ai vu des annonces je me demandent
vraiment si c'était réglementé il y
avait des arnaques moi j'ai pas cherché
au cru parce que je suis boursière un
tout petit échelon donc je pense que
c'est pas suffisant je pense pas que
j'aurais eu le logement et en plus il
fallait que j'ai mon logement en mai
donc j'avais pouvais pas attendre
septembre donc il y avit plein de
conditions qui fait que je pouvais pas
avoir le cru et là pour chercher j'ai
passé quand même de TR mois à chercher
un logement c'était long et j'avais peur
de pas trouver ou de me retrouver avec
quelque chose ou par exemple il y a les
toilettes sur le palier la douche dans
la cuisine enfin des choses comme ça où
je pense que c'est pas vraiment des
logements descents où ils sont tout
petits sous les toits sans isolation
mais je me suis dit bon j'ai pas le
choix il faut bien que j'habite quelque
part voilà vous êtes reconnu un peu dans
les cas qu'on a pu voir là on voit quand
même des jeunes qui vivent en colocation
qui ont pas vraiment même d'adresse pour
certains tellement ça paraît compliqué
qui habitent à droite à gauche bah je
pense que moi j'ai eu le privilège de
toujours finalement trouver quelque
chose mais comme je crée du contenu pour
les étudiants je sais que beaucoup me
demandent des conseils et là on est en
bah on est mi-octobre et j'ai encore
tous les jours des messages de personnes
qui me disent tu as des astuces on est
en octobre j'ai toujours pas de logement
comment faire donc moi je me je me vois
dans toutes les pages ouvertes à faire
toujours recharger la page pour voir
s'il y a un nouveau truc qui arrive mais
je pense que j'ai beaucoup de
témoignages étudiants qui me remontent
et qui me enfin où je vois que en fait
les gens il trouvent pas surtout dans
les grandes villes c'est tellement
saturé que bah on trouve pas ou quand on
trouve c'est indécent comme prix c'est
voilà oui indescent comme prix c'est
justement pour ça que vous avez mis en
place votre association
Antoine on voilà l'cadrement des loyers
aujourd'hui il est très loin d'être
respecté partout qu'est-ce que vous avez
observé hein il est effectivement loin
d'être respecté notamment à Paris euh
donc là le dernier rapport de la
fondation abépierre qui est sorti en
septembre dernier fait état de 28 % de
non respect dans cadrement des voyé à
Paris 34 à Lyon 37 à Bordeaux et même 41
% en scène saint-is donc ça concerne des
dizaines de milliers de personnes donc
c'est encore pire ailleurs oui oui oui
en scène saint-is en fait en général
plus la réglementation a été mis en
vigueur récemment moins c'est respecté
qu'à Montpellier c'est assez bien
respecté pour le coup euh et donc oui ça
concerne des milliers de personnes qui
sont locataires dans ces grandes villesl
qui perdent en moyenne 200 € sur leur
loyer c'est le mon temp le dépassement
moyen donc c'est colossal quand on parle
de pouvoir d'achat chez les jeunes 200 €
par mois c'est et et comment font les
propriétaires alors est-ce que ils
frontalement ils vont au-delà des des
loyers autorisés est-ce qu'ils ont leurs
astuces eu aussi ils sont ils sont assez
innovants ouais sur pour pour contourner
le l'encadrement des loyers concrètement
il y a deux irrégularités majeures de
par rapport à l'encadrement loyer il y a
ce qu'on va appeler le dépassement de
loyer pur c'est-à-dire que en fonction
des car des caractéristiques du logement
euh le loyer va être défini c'estàdire
en fonction de la localisation du nombre
de mètres carrés s'il est meublé ou non
on va atteindre un prix donc par exemple
Paris pour un 30 m² ça va être 700 € si
votre loyer est de 800 € inscrite sur le
bas 800 € vous payez trop cher et donc
dans ce cas-là vous avez une possibilité
de de vous retourner votre propriétaire
il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle le
complément de loyer donc là qui est
beaucoup plus flou juridiquement et les
propriétaires sen saisissent assez bien
où ils vont pouvoir justifier d'un de
dépasser ce plafond au motif que par
exemple il y a un balcon une une
nouvelle télé dans le dans le la
location de meublé ça et ça c'est pas en
cadré déplacement alors la loi va par
exemple les toilettes sur le palier on
ne peut pas mettre un complément de
loyer s' y a des toilettes sur le palier
ça c'est assez clair par contre ça va
définir ce qu'on peut pas mettre mais ça
va définir complément de loyer si on a
les toilettes à l'intérieur euh oui par
exemple et ça je pense qu'on pourrait
retrouver dans des bails dans des beau
locatifs cette mention là donc il y a
plusieurs moyens pour contner
l'encadrement les loyer et les
propriétaires sont saisiss çaz bien on
va continuer le tour des témoignages on
va aller voir Eden gundolp bonjour Vous
habitez à Lille vous avez 23 ans et
d'année on parlait hein des des des
bailleurs qui sont abusifs vous aussi
vous en avez connu dans votre parcours
de de locataire racontez-nous euh et
bien moi euh ça a été très compliqué
pour trouver un logement parce que je
suis je suis issu de de l'AZ du coup je
n'avais pas de ouais voilà de d' sociale
à l'enfance et je n'avais pas de de
Garon du coup euh j'ai eu beaucoup de de
bailleurs qui m'ont refusé tout
simplement même si j'avais euh la
garantie visale autorisé h et euh bah du
coup il y a j'ai moi je suis passé par
les foyers jeunes travailleurs aussi dit
habitat jeune qui sont ouvert aux
étudiants aux aux gens qui sont euh
ressortissant de leur pays ou euh aussi
au jeunes travailleurs comme c'est
indiqué
et du coup bah il y a une date il a une
date butoire quand on enfyer jeunes
travailleurs c'est-à-dire que bah c'est
3 ans maximum et au bout de 3 ans soit
on n pas fini nos études ou soit on
rentre dans la vie active mais on n pas
forcément on a toujours pas de garant on
a juste nous et donc en général les les
bailleurs demandent trois fois le le
loyer et moi il y en a eu le salaire et
moi il y en a une fois qui m'a pas
demandé qui m'a pas qui ne m'a pas
demandé ça c'était dans une colocation
du coup et euh en fait ce qui s'est ce
qui s'est révéé ensuite c'est qu'il
m'avait fait signer un un bail avec une
clause abusive qui était que je ne
devais inviter personne chez moi pour
dormir à condition d'être sinon j'étais
viré quoi et j'avais déjà versé le le le
bail la garantie et cetera et du coup
bah c'est là où où j'étais dans le foyer
jeune travailleurs où là ils mont ils
m'ont aidé aussi à à me sortir de de ça
parce que bah tout seul c'est c'est
compliqué et il y a des bailleurs il le
voit très bien quand on est tout seul et
du coup bah il se pensent tout permis
quoi alors vous nous parlez un peu de
tous les problèmes que vous avez eu Eden
c'est important peut-être de dire aussi
pour ceux qui nous regardent que vous
avez pu trouver des organismes qui vous
sont venus en aide lesquels
euh bah principalement le le Foy jeune
travailleur là où j'étais à Lille donc
betan où il y a une toute une équipe
socio-éducative au quotidien avec nous
et euh bah du coup moi c'est
principalement eux qui m'ont aidé pour
des aides alimentaires parce que bah je
touchais que la bourse donc c'était
c'était très compliqué
euh après ensuite ils m'ont aussi
inscrit dans des parcours de logements
sociaux en ouais dans le logement social
même si je n'ai toujours pas de nouvelle
du coup
et bah sinon ils m'ont aussi aider dans
les démarches administratives qui me
concernent plus personnellement et et
Eden vous vous habitez où aujourd'hui
quelle est quelle est votre solution de
logement aujourd'hui ah ben aujourd'hui
c'est c'est pas une solution de logement
durable c'est la colocation j'ai pas pu
faire autrement là je suis en CDI 35 he
et malgré ça les les les bailleurs
refusent si je ne P pas minimum euh
trois fois leur loyer et comme j'habite
à l'Î les les loyers sont extrêmement
chers et euh moi faut que j'ai un loyer
minimum maximum à 440 € et clairement à
Lille on a on a quoi un 20 m² pour 440
€. et c'est pas c'est pas un logement
durable ça et ben merci merci beaucoup
Eden d'avoir répondu à toutes mes
questions merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage he qui nous permet d'avoir un
aperçu de toutes les difficultés de de
logement que peuvent vivre les jeunes on
va essayer maintenant un petit peu
d'élargir le prisme de comprendre un
petit peu tout ça in grid napi pourquoi
est-ce que le marché locatif aujourd'hui
est aussi tendu quel quel est son état
aujourd'hui alors on l'a bien vu dans
les témoignages une partie des jeunes
loges reste sur leurs parents donc on
dit que c'est à peu près un/ers 50 %
sont sur le marché locatif justement
privé et à peu près 15 % sont dans dans
des résidences étudiantes dont enfin sur
ces 15 % un peu plus de la moitié dans
le social dont on a h donc après sont
des résidences étudiantes privé
concernant le marché locatif privé qui
celui que qui est notamment pour
certaines zones universitaires régies
par l'encadrement des loyers mais en
fait il y a une pénurie de l'offre par
rapport à la demande faut quand même pas
oublier logement oui mais il faut quand
même pas oublier le côté démographique
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on a les les
les les les jeunes de 20 ans comme vous
le dites dans votre émission qui arrive
d'un d'un baby boom des années 2000 qui
arrive ça représente pratiquement 14 %
de la population euh on a également
40000 étudiants par an donc on a un
croissement de du volume des étudiants
ce qu'on appelle la massification de
l'enseignement supérieur sont deux
facteurs à prendre en compte qui
viennent sur le marché locatif privé
alors que celui-ci d'un point de vue de
l'offre c'est amoindri notamment avec on
va dire essentiellement depuis 2015 une
le fait de l'économie numérique et donc
des plateforme de location locatif
meublé de courte durée qui viennent
perturber très fortement le marché en
étant pas encadré notamment et qui sont
un véritable sujet notamment pour les
les jeunes étudiants parce que c'est
généralement dans des villes qui sont
par ailleurs des des villes très
touristiques je pense que à Toulouse je
pense à Montpellier je pense à Rennes
par exemple à Rennes la population
étudiante ça représente 8 % euh des de
la population de de l'aair urbaine donc
on voit bien un taux d'accroissement un
taux qui s'accroit de de population
étudiante dans des villes qui sont par
ailleurs touristiques et dont le locate
meublé touristique de courte durée vient
grever le marché locatif sans qu'on ait
pour autant des observatoires
véritablement qui qui viennent observer
la chose donc on voit qu'on est dans un
marché complètement bouleversé depuis
quelques années le taux d'effort des
jeunes consacrés au logement on a
quelques chiffre il est deux fois
supérieur à la moyenne générale 22 %
pour les 18 25 ans 18,5 % pour les 25 29
ans contre 10,3 % pour la
population général gen elgo on se dit en
fait ils sont coincés de tous les côtés
les les jeunes ils sont on le voit ça
représente un budget plus important par
rapport à leur bourse que pour le reste
de la population et en plus ce sont ceux
qui ont les carrières qui commenence
donc ils ont le moins de garantie donc
effectivement c'est une situation très
difficile oui c'est ça et le moins de
garantie pendant plus longtemps
c'està-dire que avant d'avoir enfin dans
les dans les années 70 80 on commençait
à avoir un emploi stable autour de 20
ans aujourd'hui il faut attendre 27 ans
donc en fait c'est une précarité aussi
qui alors qui peut être choisie on peut
faire des choses mais qui est souvent
aussi aussi subi et c'est vrai que
derrière derrière ces chiffres en fait
il faut il faut il faut voir ce que ça
signifie c'est-à-dire que en en moyenne
si on parle des étudiants en moyenne les
étudiants ils ont allez 900 € pour pour
vivre alors ça vient de leur famille
pour certains mais il y a un/art des
étudiants que leur familles ne peuvent
pas du tout aider et pour autant qu'ils
sont pas boursiers ou en tout cas pas
dans une mesure qui permet d'aller dans
des résidences
universita qui sont qui sont en nombre
insuffisant en plus résiden
universitaires et les et les loyers en
revanche c'est en moyenne de 500 600 et
ça peut aller jusqu'à 800 € dans les
grandes agglomérations parce que c'est
ça le le le problème des jeunes et des
étudiants c'est qu'il recherchent des
petits logements dans les grandes
agglomérations c'est-à-dire là où
justement l'offre et et et l'offre à un
prix que l'on peut se se permettre et
est très rare est très rare c'est le
plus compliqué à trouver
quoi un petit logement à un prix descend
dans avec la concurrence que que vous
exprimiez sur une concurrence multiple
hein c'est-à-dire que à la fois ce que
vous disiez de du tourisme dans ces ces
zonesl ce que disait aussi Antoine
c'est-à-dire d'un encadrement qui ne
fonctionne pas encore tout à fait enfin
qui s'améliore mais qui ne fonctionne
pas tout à fait or oui j'éta surprise
parce que ça s'améliore par exemple
quand même à Paris on a l'impression que
ça doit être le pire du pire mais comme
l'encadrement des loyers
à un certain âge ou a été adopté depuis
un certain temps par la mairie on
commence à obtenir quand même des
résultats ça s'améliore mais pas sur les
petites surface justement petit surfac
qui son dans dans le dernier rapport de
la Fondation avpierre ils font état pour
un moin 20 m² il y a une chance sur de
pour que le le loyer soit pas respecté
et pour un moins de 15 m² c'est 800/10
pour que le loyer dépasse le le
plafonnement donc les 28 % de
propriétaires qui ne jouent pas le jeu
c'est majoritairement des petites
surfaces euh oui oui globalement ça va
être ça va être ça sur des plus 30 ou 40
m Carr ça va plutôt être respecté vous
avez eu une expression en préparant
cette émission vous avez dit le logement
c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce qu'est-ce
que vous vouliez dire par là bah
c'est-à-dire que là par exemple en ce
moment on parle beaucoup et je pense que
ça vient ça ne vient qu'à santuer les
les choses on parle beaucoup du des
pouvoirs d'achat évidemment quand je
vous disais tout à l'heure on a quand on
est étudiant on a en moyenne et ça cache
des disparités très importantes mais on
a en moyenne 900 € pour vivre avec un
loyer qui est souvent enfin un logement
qui est entre 500 et et 600 € regardez
ce qui ce qui reste après il faut se
déplacer qui a un autre poste important
quand on est quand on est étudiant en
moyenne les étudiants ils habitent pas
juste à côté euh justement ça serait euh
ça serait trop beau et et ça serait trop
facile et il faut l'alimentation euh
voyez et l'alimentation même si vous
prenez un étudiant là il y a des repas à
1 € il y a des repas à 3,30 € même si
vous cumulez tout ça vous arrivez de
toute façon à 150 200 € donc regardez en
fait il reste rien à vivre et parfois on
dépasse en fait l'argent donc
aujourd'hui il y a un étudiant sur sur
qu qui dit qu'il n'arrive pas du tout à
vivre avec seses ses revenus mensuel et
et quand je dis oui l'éléphant in the
room c'est c'est parce que aujourd'hui
la la question du logement en fait c'est
une question sous-jacente pour
l'ensemble des Français c'està-dire que
l'ensemble des Français ce qui le
logement c'est ce qui a le plus augmenté
en proportion et en valeur dans les
budgets des Français problème numéro
pour tout le monde et c'est et c'est et
du coup c'est vrai que quand on se pose
la question aujourd'hui de ok on a 20 %
d'inflation depuis 2 ans sur
l'alimentaire mais regardez je pense que
vous en parlerez mieux que moi mais ce
qui s'est passé depuis 25 ans sur sur
les logements est est incroyable aussi
c'est du plus du FO 3 du X 4 selon les
les les zones et les territoire donc
c'est pour ça on on va s'intéresser
beaucoup à certains sujets mais celui-ci
en fait c'est c'est celui qui à la base
pose beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes et
beaucoup de problèmes d'inégalité
peut-être on y reviendra aussi on va y
revenir oui ça POS également des
problèmes pour les entreprises aussi
parce qu'on parle des étudiants mais on
peut aussi parler des jeunes actifs dans
cette âge cette tranche d'âge il y a
aussi des entreprises aujourd'hui qui
n'arrivent pas à recruter ou à garder
également parce que tout simplement le
le jeune salarié n'arrive pas à se loger
ou des étudiants qui terminent leurs
études qui n'arrivent pas se loger pour
prendre donc ça peut être une une piste
que les entreprises se mêlent du sujet
alors elles s'en mêlent d'ailleurs elle
commenc à réfléchir on on va parler hein
tout à l'heure des des solutions à
envisag on a beaucoup marché parlé
pardon du marché locatif je vous propose
qu'on s'intéresse aussi plus
spécifiquement au logement en étudiant
et notamment aux résidences étudiantes
et pour ça on va accueillir Quentin
[Musique]
Calmet bonjour Quentin bonjour Tam
bonjour à tous alors cette année encore
de nombreux étudiants de nombreux
étudiantes ont galéré ou galèent encore
pour trouver un logement voilà on le
comprend depuis le début de cette
émission effectivement on a vu en plus
quelques exemples très emblématiques
comme par exemple Lena 3e année à la fac
est contrainte de vivre dans un
camping-car sur le parking de sa faculté
on avait lu ainsi dans West France à
Rennes la pression sur les les
résidences étudiantes est l'une des plus
fortes de France le cru reçoit cinq
demandes pour un logement en Cité
étudiante et estime qu'il faudrait 1500
places supplémentaires pour répondre à
la demande regardons justement quelques
chiffres th réunis par le magazine
l'Étudiant en 2022 il y a 173000
logements gérés par le CROUS on compte
par ailleurs 60000 places dans des
logements sociaux gérés par des
organismes HLM ou par des associations
il existe donc tamame 233000 logements à
caractère social disponible en France
alors que le pays et bien il compte
700000 étudiants boursiers et enfin Tam
5 % des étudiants sont logés dans les
140000 logements du parcs privés des
résidences dédiées on le voit donc les
possibilités offertes que ce soit en
résidence universitaire ou en structure
dédiée privée reste largement en DEA des
besoins et ça pousse donc de nombreux
étudiants à se tourner vers le marché
immobilier classique voilà on le dit en
cette rentrée 2023 il y a 3 millions
d'étudiants inscrits dans l'enseignement
supérieur il manquerait au total
20000 logements avec une situation plus
qui se dégrade d'année en année il y a
de plus en plus d'étudiants ça vous
venez de le dire et de moins en moins de
logements car l'état du parc se dégrade
des logements deviennent insalubres
certains studio ou petits appartements
ne sont plus louables et le phénomène
Airbnb n'a pas aidé il tend un peu plus
le marché locatif et autre problème pour
les étudiants qui finalement trouvent un
apportement c'est donc le problème des
prix exactement et ça c'est
contreintuitif dans un marché qui
généralement et bien voit ses prix
baisser en France en 2023 les prix
globaux et bien ils baissent d'1 % en
moyenne mais pas les petites surfaces
celles recherchées par les étudiants
selon l'Unef les étudiants
débourseraient ainsi en moyenne
570 € par mois pour se loger vous le
disiez à l'instant c'est 60 % du budget
ce chiffre est cependant très variable
en fonction de là où l'on cherche un
logement les loyers les plus chers sont
à Paris avec 881 € en moyenne mais aussi
nanter rcrétaille 734 € dans ces deux
académies Tam merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour toutes ces explications Maë
Quentin a commencé en parlant du cas des
étudiants boursiers vous avez été
boursière mais pour vous l'un des
problèmes c'est que juste votre bourse
vous l'avez vu fluctuer forcément à la
baisse et puis vous vous y attendiez pas
forcément comment ça s'est passé alors
la Bourse est calculée sur le revenu des
parents donc en fait ça ça peut
facilement fluctuer étant donné que mon
père par exemple il étaé au chômage puis
il a fait de l'intérim puis il a
travaillé un peu et pas beaucoup donc en
fait comme c'était calculé par exemple
pour 2020 c'était les revenus de 2018 si
mon père par exemple 2 ans avant avait
fait de l'intérim ma situation changeait
mais du tout au tout j'ai perdu je pense
300 € de bourse sur 2 ans ou au début je
300 € sachant que vous aviez combien je
suis passé de 400 € à 100 € ouais
sachant que voilà donc en fait et vous
vous y attendiez pas vous aviez un
avertissement vous disiez attention euh
ben je pensais que j'allais pouvoir en
fait ils disent toujours que si c'est
calculé et que le mon père était encore
au chômage je pouvais faire des rappels
ou demander à ce que ma situation soit
réévaluée donc j'ai fait les dossiers
tout ça mais au final ils m'ont dit que
c'était pas possible où ils ont réévalué
un tout petit peu ils m'ont augmenté de
50 € ma bourse ce qui fait qu'en fait
finalement je passais d'avoir mon loyer
à peu près couvert donc bourse+ APL mon
loyer était couvert à plus du tout avoir
un loyer couvert donc me retrouver à
travailler des heures que je pense ind
descendre c'est-à-dire 20h en plus d'un
d'étude à plein temps c'est et ça a tout
déséquilibré enfin c'est vous avez
réussi quand même à comment dire à avoir
vos années malgré ça vos années
scolaires je veux dire à exam j'ai
réussi mais parce que moi j'ai vraiment
je pense que j'ai opté pour l'option
travailler beaucoup mais pouvoir vivre
normalement j'aurais pu en fait être
malade ou quoi que ce soit et et ne pas
du tout pouvoir travailler mais je me
suis j'ai pris sur moi j'ai travaillé
pour pouvoir m'en sortir mais je pense
que il y a plein d'étudiants qui peuvent
pas non plus faire ça sachant que moi
j'ai un peu des j'ai des facilités
académiques donc je peux me permettre de
travailler enfin si j'avais des
difficultés dans mes études j'aurais pas
du tout pu travailler autant d'heure
déjà que là j'ai pris du retard par des
explication pour tous ces étudiants qui
lâchent c'était enfin parfois je savais
que moi la veille des examens ben
j'étais en train de de travailler au
babycity jusqu'à 22h le soir et je pis
j'arrivais à 8h j'avais mon examen je
savais que tous les autres ils avaient
pu ils avaient pu bosser en fait c'est
vraiment des inégalités parce qu'après
aussi là comme il disait dans le dans le
reportage si finalement on fait des
études plus longues parce qu'on redouble
parce qu'on arrive pas parce qu'on s'en
sort pas financièrement on se retrouve
aussi exclus de logement des logements
sociaux donc en fait c'est un peu c'est
toujours les mêmes personnes qui qui se
retrouve à enfin qui se retrouve face
aux inégalités GGO est-ce que qu'on
devrait repenser le système des des
bourses étudiantes quand on voit là bien
comme notre situation peut changer du
tout au tout pour quelque chose qu'on
avait pas forcément prévu je crois que
vous aviez aussi dit parfois on vous a
sorti de votre bourse votre travail
d'été l'argent que vous aviez pu gagner
à ce moment-là enfin des choses
auxqueles on s'attend pas nécessairement
si on av pas plongé le nez dans le
fonctionnement des bourses ouais c'est
c'est ça la précarité si vous voulez
c'est pas la la pauvreté c'est quand on
a des des des revenus qui peuvent être
assez stable et qu'on qu'on peut gérer
avec ces ces revenus là c'est c'est
autre chose enfin évidemment faut faut
ça se considère mais la précarité c'est
pas c'est de pas savoir en terme de
revenu de quoi demain sera fait et c'est
ça qui pose aujourd'hui le le un gros
problème surtout comme quand on le
disait tout à l'heure cette cette
période en fait la la la jeunesse si on
caricature s allongé de 10 ans en fait
cette période de transition et donc tout
ce qui va être susceptible justement
d'apporter de la stabilisation plutôt
que de la déstabilisation comme c'est le
cas là surtout à retard en fait on le
voit c'està-dire c'est c'est
contracyclique en fait c'est les les
aides boursières mais ça ça va pouvoir
c'est de nature effectivement aider
c'est pour ça qu'il y a des réflexions
autour du revenu universel ou autour de
de choses comme ça qui pourrait être d
stabilisateurs qu'on demandait notamment
14 présidents d'université hein dans une
tribune qu'ils ont adressé au
Gouvernement qui a été publié dans le
monde 1000 € pour chaque étudiant ça ça
pourrait être une solution comme bah oui
c'est-à-dire comme le disait ma
aujourd'hui alors il y a il y a à peu
près un étudiant sur deux qui a une
activité professionnelle mais ça compte
aussi les les les apprentis donc en
revanche il y en a un sur C un étudiant
sur 5 à peu près qui a une activité
professionnel qui est justement en
concurrence vraiment frontale avec ses
études c'est-à-dire le volume d'heure et
est est très important effectivement
faut être soit très brillant comme comme
les mail mais malgré tout c'est c'est
c'est difficile et et et pour beaucoup
en revanche c'est c'est quelque chose
qui va obérer vraiment les les les
études alors nous sommes aussi en visio
avec le sénateur de l'ER sénateur
Renaissance Didier Rambo bonjour bonjour
Didier Rambo je voudrais un peu avoir
votre réaction au débat qu'on a sur ce
plateau sur les bourses étudiantes qui
ont la vu peut-être demanderaiit à être
peut-être revue et puis et puis aussi
cette idée peut-être d'avoir un un
revenu universel et étudiants comme l'
demandé certains présidents d'université
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire tout ça
euh d'abord alors d'abord vous dire que
je suis très très heureux de participer
à à ce débat que j'écoute depuis le
début et puis étant même un peu
personnellement concerné puisque j'ai
encore un fils qui est en situation
d'apprentissage et je sais ce que ça
représente que de chercher un logement
et quand bien même on trouve un logement
ce qu'on demande des fois aux parents en
terme de de caution de de fournir des
attest de de des bulletins de salaire
voire même des déclarations de revenu je
trouve que ça va ça va un peu loin
concernant plus particulièrement votre
question sur les bourses bon étant
membre de la de la de la commission des
finances du Sénat et donc suivant de
près tous les budgets notamment le le
budget de l'enseignement supérieur nous
n'avons pas baissé les bourses ça je
tiens à le dire alors effectivement il
peut y avoir des situations au cas par
cas comme l'a dit d'ailleurs l'étudiant
qui est sur votre plateau effectivement
s'il y a une évolution sociale de de sa
situation et de ses parents efftivement
le montant des bourses peut-être revu
mais je je tiens à redire très très
fermement nous n'avons pas baissé le le
budget des bourses faudrait soit plus
visisible vous comprenez queon puisse
mieux s s'y attendre mieux anticiper le
cas de Maë elle dit voilà mon père a
fait de l'intérim pendant un an en 2018
et je découvre 2 ans plus tard que du
coup je passe de 300 € de bourse de 400
€ de bourse à 100 € et puis a
ceentend il vudrait mieux
contemporainiser ça je suis arrivé à le
dire un peu les les les effectivement le
le le montant de de de ces bourses
sûrement que dans le
fonctionnement on peut on peut faire
nettement mieux à ce niveau-là et je
peux comprendre la situation
de de Madame étudiante que ouais il faut
essayer d'avoir une meilleure lisibilité
sur sur l'année qui vient pour pour
mieux pour mieux apprécier et et ajuster
cette situationou euh Didier rambau on a
aussi beaucoup on a commencé à parler de
la question
du prix des petites surfaces qui sont
plébiscitées par les jeunes actifs et
par les étudiants notamment dans les
dans les grandes métropoles alors il y
en a certain nombre qui ont mis en place
l'encadrement des loyers mais on l'a
compris il y a quand même plein de
moyens pour un propriétaire de ne pas
respecter cet encadrement des loyers
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire pour pour
que bah cette loi soit appliquéeors
alors d'abord moi je pense qu'il faut
peut-être se poser la vraie question
d'abord du problème du logement des
jeunes et des étudiants parce que je
pense que c'est d'abord un problème
d'offre faut-il encadrer les loyers
attention c'est sûrement peut-être une
fausse bonne idée parce que ce n'est pas
parce qu'on va plafonner les loyers que
l'on va augmenter le le stock de
logement le vrai problème c'est comment
on a davantage de quantité de logement
et donc on a un vrai problème de de de
de construction de de logement étudiant
qui n'est pas un sujet facile hein il
faut je crois qu'il faut avoir le
courage de se le dire aujourd'hui les
les maires bâtisseurs que l'on a connu
pendant des années mais sont
malheureusement de moins en moins parce
que c'est très difficile de construire
aujourd'hui dans dans notre pays on ne
supporte plus devant chez soi
effectivement bah de voir monter de
nouveaux programmes immobiliers faire du
logement étudiant aussi pour un maire
c'est un double problème d'abord parce
qu'il va avoir des problèmes de
voisinage c'est clair aujourd'hui B les
jeunes ont leur propre leur propre mode
de vie et
cetera et des des questions de
cohabitation peuvent se poser et donc
décourager des élus locaux à faire
davantage logement étudiant et puis il y
a aussi un petit peu le je dirais le le
retour sur investissement construire du
logement aujourd'hui pour une commune
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça rapporte
à partir du moment où on a on a supprimé
par exemple la taxe d'habitation que moi
personnellement je je remets pas en
cause mais il faudra à un moment donné
qu'on se pose la le la question de quel
impôt résidentiel dans notre pays à
partir du moment où on occupe un
logement dans une commune il faut bien
qu'il y ait un retour aussi qu'il ait
une parti qu'il a un lien qu'on recrée
ce lien
h je sais je sors unjet mais il est il
est il est lié
aussi à comment on encourage et comment
on peut construire parce que le vrai
sujet à mon avis il est là c'est d'abord
qu'on est davantage de logement dans
notre pays et plus particulièrement pour
les étudiants alors vous nêtes pas reste
avec nousamb mais je voudrais faire
réagir à ce que vous dites parce que
Antoine vous votre association s'occupe
justement de faire respecter la loi sur
l'encadrement des loyers qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire entendre un
parlementaire qui dit c'est pas
forcément ça le problème le problème
c'est surtout le stock de logement
disponible j'entends que que l'offre
n'est pas n'est pas suffisante mais elle
va pas arriver tout de suite donc là on
peut faire les deux en attendant la
question de prix reste quand même
essentielle et notamment je reviens sur
les résidences étudiantes de parc privés
qui ne sont pas concernés par
l'encadrement des loyers et donc ça à
savoir c'est des entre 10 et 20 m²r dans
des résidences privées qui sont pas
considéré comme des bailes d'habitation
traditionnel et on arrive à des prix qui
qui sont exorbitants si l'encadrement
était mis en place pour ces résidences
là le loyer serait deux fois moins cher
donc et en général c'est des étudiants
qui sortte du lycée qui entre 18 et 20
ans on des revenus très faibles je
trouve que là pour le coup l'encadrement
des loyer il est pas mis en place il
aurait un réel intérêt pour ces
étudiants là donc j'entends la question
de l'offre mais le prix dans tous les
cas il faut il faut le réguler aussirid
napi qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire vous
l'encadrement des loyers c'est ça fait
partie des solutions aujourd'hui c'est
une solu à court terme en attendant la
production de nouveau logement qu'est-ce
que ça ça dépend de quoi on parle la
production de nouveaux logement ça va
être un peu difficile mais il y a quand
même des mesures pour
encourager la production notamment de de
foyers de jeunes travailleurs enfin pour
les pour les étudiants mais de manière
générale on revient vraiment à la
répartition de l'offre hein le parc
locatif privé il existe il est mal àoué
donc l'idée c'est de faire revenir une
partie de ce parc locatif pour loger des
jeunes travailleurs par exemple ou bien
des jeunes étudiants le parc il y a des
y a des résidences comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire du coup ce qu'on
entendait un petit peu rés une question
de fiscalité de du me du meublé he c'est
un véritable sujet aujourd'hui
actuellement sur la fiscalité des des
logements en meublie touristique de
courte durée en fait la crise c'est une
crise tout simplement du logement de
locatif déjà intermédiaire donc le
logement social ben il le problème c'est
le parcours résidentiel parce que
logement social mais actuellement il est
tellement sollicité parce qu'une partie
des jeunes notamment ceux qui viennent
de d'être recruté ben ne peuvent pas
aller dans le parc locatif intermédiaire
on va dire et donc se réfugie dans le
parc social qui lui est des exang alors
par exemple le cru également il y a eu
quand même des mesures pour augmenter le
nombre de résidences de crus mais
aujourd'hui le cru c'est les années 50
donc aujourd'hui il faut rénover ces
résidences donc tout l'effort il est
d'abord mis dans les opérations de
rénovation des bâtis après il y a
également l'effort sur des foyers qui
sont notamment gérés par des
associations avec des bailleurs sociaux
le là aussi on a des résidences qui se
créent mais ça ne fait pas euh je veux
dire ça ne répond pas à la demande j'ai
j'ai commencé en en parlant de cette
demande qui devient de plus en plus
croissante il de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui se forment donc à un
moment donné voilà on est en
déséquilibre entre l'offre donc il y a
véritablement un problème d'offre il y a
un problème également on peut pas
construire parce que on va construire où
aujourd'hui on est dans une une une
question de rareté du foncier notamment
de faire en sorte que de ne plus
artificialiser des sols donc on
artificialisation nette voilà donc on a
le le le le le foncier éventuellement
des des campus universitaires sur ces
sur ces sur ces pardon sur ces fonciers
on construit des logements des
résidences privés on a aussi des
résidences qui appartiennent à des à des
établissements de grandes écoles qui ont
leur propres résidence étudiantes qui
viennent aussi résoudre un peu la crise
du logement pour ces grandes écoles le
problème il est surtout dans les cités
universitaires des universités publiques
hein il est là le problème en fait c'est
justement de loger les étudiants des
universités publiques pas les étudiants
des grandes écoles qui ont déjà leur
résidence et là il y a un problème
justement de foncier de financement de
et puis surtout moi je pense réellement
de ce de ce 55 % des étudiants logent
dans le locatif intermédiaire qui n'est
pas régulé dont l'encadrement des loyers
est uniquement est limité tout qu' fait
n'est pas respecté et surtout où en fait
le c'est pas du tout rentable de loger
un étudiant tout simplement alors
l'impact c'est c'est quoi donc
aujourd'hui i ça fait qu'on a des
centres urbains qui se vident de des des
jeunes en terme d'habitat des des jeunes
qui n'ont plus accès à ces centres
urbains aujourd'hui g elgo ben en tout
cas oui ça ça complique et en fait je je
je pense qu'il y a aussi au-delà enfin
que la question du logement étudiant
signale effectivement la question du
logement et de et des inégalités de
logement de de manière plus plus global
en fait en en France c'està direire que
le Conseil juste le Conseil d'analyse
économique a mis le doigt sur sur
quelque chose qui qui explique aussi
alors au-delà du manque d'offre mais
malgré tout comment cette offre et
comment les prix fonctionne c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui il y a 3,5 % des
Français qui possèdent 3,5 % des
Français qui possèdent plus 50 % de
l'offre locative privée c'estàdire
qu'ils ont plus de CQ logements en en
moyenne donc on voit bien que là on voit
le mieux les inégalités et là en fait
enfin voilà l'offre la demande enfin on
comprend très bien que
on est en situation où euh euh
évidemment là il y a une attribution
enfin le le parc locatif en fait il est
concentré la propriété de ce parc
locatif est concentré sur très très peu
de de français et de l'autre côté il y a
aussi alors il y a 2,8 millions de
Français qui attendent des logements
sociaux euh et il y a aussi là aussi une
pénurie de logement social et et il y
avait une mobilité dans le logement
social qui pourrait être une solution en
fait pour les jeunes mais par exemple on
voit à Paris euh à à Paris dans les
années 80 c'était un logement sur social
sur quatre qui était occupé par une
personne de moins de 30 ans par un jeune
aujourd'hui c'est un logement social sur
20 donc on voit aussi au-delà en fait
des questions euh bien sûr de résidence
universitaire au-delà des questions
parce que ça pose cette concentration
des logements euh dans dans un petit
nombre de Français posent la question
quand même de de l'encadrement et
au-delà de ça aussi les questions de
logements sociaux et ça ça concerne les
étudiants les jeunes chez qui justement
euh il y a il y a cette cette nécessité
presque d'habiter euh d'habiter dans les
grands centres urbains ou d'habiter
proches des grands centres urbains euh
mais ça concerne aussi tous les tous les
Français voulez réagir oui je voulais
réagir un peu sur cette question
justement de la propriété locative elle
est du logement locatif privé
intermédiaire elle est aux mains de qui
pendant très longtemps c'était des
grands investisseurs institutionnels
hein des compagnies d'assurance
principalement qui détenaient des des
parcs de logement ils les ont cédés dans
les années début des années 2000 c'était
les ventil à découpe donc beaucoup de
ménages se sont retrouvés propriétaires
de de d'investiss de de leur principale
résidence ont également par des mesures
d' de de de comment on va dire de
défiscalisation d' d'incitation à
l'investissement locatif ce ont acheté
notamment de l'investissement locatif
privé tout ça allait bien pour justement
loger des personnes sauf que depuis le
l'avanement des plateformes euh de de
location Internet et notamment de du
Airbnb ou des autres plateformes et bien
en fait depuis 2015 c'est beaucoup plus
rentable pour des raisons fiscales et et
NOTAM principalement pour des raisons
fiscales de loger euh ces parcs locatifs
qui allait au départ initialement étit
pour de la location privée pour des
jeunes actifs par exemple bah de le de
le détourner pour des locations
saisonnières de très courte durée
notamment il est quand même là le
problème he le regarder notamment à
Rennes notamment dans des villes
universitaires comme Rennes Montpellier
ou bien également à ex-marseille donc
c'est important de le signaler Antoine
est-ce que c'est un quelque chose que
vous créz aussi parce que des
propriétaires il peuvent se dire ah bah
très bien l'encadrement des loyers me
dérange si je loue en Airbnb je veis
plus avoir ce problème est-ce que vous
dites aussi ah ben alors si on le on
comment dire on applique l'encadrement
des loyers de façon très strict on va
voir tous ces propriétaires qui vont
peut-être aussi fuir ce marché locatif B
c'est c'est déjà le cas et c'est pour ça
que nous aussi dans notre association on
on veut vraiment avoir un un pldoyer
auprès des élus nationaux et locaux pour
que cet encadrement de l'ER il soit mis
en cohérence avec aussi une régulation
du marché Airbnb et des locations
touristique parce queeffectivement les
propriétaires vont s'engouffrer euh dans
le marché qui va être le plus
intéressant sont pour eux donc il faut
vraiment faire ça en même temps sinon
l'encadrement des voyer effectivement ça
risque de ne pas fonctionner très bien
de marchés très concurrentiell de peties
surface en fait de studio ou de Thin
alors il y a eu des propositions qui ont
été faites des parlementaires qui ont
planché sur le sujet de la précarité
étudiante et notamment en terme de
logement voilà quelques propositions
faites par une mission d'information de
l'Assemblée qui proposé fin 2021 la
production de plus de logements de
petite taille le fait de massifier le
recours à la colocation dans le parc HLM
le fait de mobiliser le foncier
disponible de le transformer en logement
étudiant améliorer aussi l'accès aux
aides au logement pour les jeunes c'est
ce qu'on a vu d'ailleurs au début du
sujet beaucoup de jeunes qui ignorent
complètement les aides auxquelles ils
ont droit Didier rambau je voudrais
votre réaction sur sur ce sujet ce sont
deux anciens députés de la majorité
présidentielle modem et Renaissance qui
faisaient ces ces préconisations bon
qu'est-ce qui vous paraît faisable et de
façon comment dire assez rapide assez
efficace parce qu'on le voit le problème
c'est quand même un problème d'urgence
aujourd'hui hein oui c'est un problème
d'urgence mais mais même quand c'est
urgent on sait qu'on peut pas construire
des logements en quelques semaines euh
bon le foncier le vrai sujet majeur
c'est le le point de départ comme disent
certains économistes le le foncier c'est
la c'est la matière première
indispensable pour le pour le pour le
logement je pense à un autre sujet qui
est la la loi SRU vous savez la loi su
qui avait été vot é il y a quelques
années pour obliger toutes les communes
de plus de 3500 habitants à avoir un
minimum de 20 % de logement sociaux il
faudrait que que les résidences
étudiantes puissent être comptabilisé au
titre des des quotas
SRU je pense que c'est une disposition
qu'il faudrait faire faudrait réussir à
à à faire évoluer parce que encore une
fois quand je vois la proposition là que
vous mettez à l'écran mobiliser le
foncier disponible transformer en
logement étudiant oui euh mais il faut
convaincre nos élus locaux et nos maires
à le faire et
et des côtas étudiants séparés enfin
plutôt que de se dire on va prendre sur
le logement
social non mais les intégrés il faut
il il faut il faut encore encore une
fois encourager les élus locaux à le
faire parce que c'est pas évident c'est
pas iné pour aujourd'hui une équipe
municipale de faire de le jur étudiant
pour deux raisons je vous l'ai dit parce
que que un ils vont se confronter avec
des à des problèmes de voisinage qui
vont faire des recours et on sait qu'en
dans notutres pays malheureusement les
recours on sait très bien faire et ça
retarde et ça retarde et puis en terme
de recette aussi sur sur quel est le
quel est le retour sur investissement
pour une commune de faire du du logement
étudiant je crois qu'il faut il va
falloir beaucoup plus
réfléchir sur cette tax là je encore une
fois je je sais que c'est peut-être pas
dans l'air du temps mais le l'idée d'un
impôt identiel doit être doit être
travaillé des des des quôas étudiants
inclus dans dans dans les quotas plus
globaux à respecter pour les communes ça
c'est un peu ce que vous pensiez il faut
il faudrait des quotas vous dites de
logement étudiant dans dans les communes
mais je pense que les intégrer dans les
les logements HLM ça va invisibiliser le
problème des étudiants et il est déjà
très invisibilisé je pense que soit on
augmente généralement les quotas de
logements sociaux et dans ce cas-là on
intègre les logements étudiants mais je
pense 25 % dont 5 % pour le logement
étudiant par exemple il faut vraiment
traiter le problème des étudiants parce
qu'en fait on parle tout le temps de
solution d'urgence mais ça reste un
problème de fond et ça fait des années
que c'est compliqué d'être étudiant il
faut juste réfléchir au statut étudiant
et se dire on a des gens qui
investissent leur temps leur santé leur
argent dans le fait de faire des études
qui permet de développer le pays on va
leur donner une situation décente parce
qu'il y a des pays en Europe qui font ça
le Danemark par exemple vous avez je
crois 840 € brut dès lors que vous
habiter plus chez vos parents ça une
espèce d'allocation ou de on peut
appeler ça comme on veut le revenu
universelétudiant mais voilà ça ça
pourrait être une c'est pour tout le
monde ils permettent de travailler à
côté sans que ça impacte les études il y
a des études modulables en fait il y a
plein de formats différents mais là ce
qu'on fait en France c'est toujours
donner des solutions d'urgence débloquer
des budgets parce qu'on est dans
l'urgence alors que je pense que il
faudrait qu'on se dise que ai dans 5 ans
faire ses études c'est vivable c'est ça
en fait ce à quoi il faut penser juste
une je demandais quand même à didamb ce
qu'il pense de l'histoire du de de cette
de ce revenu étudiant voilà c'est vous
voyez une une étudiante qui qui qui qui
en parle on a vu les présidents
d'université ça qu'est-ce que vous vous
seriez pour ou pas l'idée du renue
universel je vouis vous dire très
franchement non je suis contre parce que
je pense que ça ça dilue la valeur de
travail premièrement alors je pré les
étudiant une allocation dès lors qu'ils
ne vivent pas chez chez les par ah vous
préférez àocation je préfère le terme
àocation effectivement comme vient de le
dire l'étudiante euh il faut que les
études puissent être vivables oui ça
c'est clair euh donc mettre chaque
citoyen chaque jeune citoyen en
situation de de pouvoir réaliser des
études effectivement une voilà revoir
sûrement le système des bourses et
d'allocation d'études je préfère ce
thème-là à celui de revenu parce que
voilà on sait que le revenu universel on
on peut s'installer
dedans vous vouliez aussi intervenir
rapidement pour revenir sur le le
caractère urgent si on doit l'anticiper
anticipons que ces études uds vont
devenir des jeunes actifs dans 4 ans
donc le problème va se reposer également
il se pose déjà actuellement pour les
jeunes actifs donc avoir 20 ans ça veut
dire avoir 20 ansus avoir la décennie de
des 20 ans en fait ça dure 10 ans donc
actuellement on parle beaucoup du
logement des jeunes mais c'est également
le logement des jeunes actifs et ça
c'est très important quand même ce
sujetlà notamment pour garder des des
jeunes actifs en France quand on voit
comme dans certains pays en Italie où
les jeunes partent notamment vers
d'autres pays hors Union européenne
c'est un véritable sujet aujourd'hui
avec le vieillissement de la population
on le sait aussi donc ça va s'accentuer
donc faisons attention que ces jeunes
actifs ces jeunes étudiants puissent
d'abord se loger mais pourront également
se loger quand ils sortiront de leurs
études et qu'ils puissent notamment
avoir ce parcours résidentiel qu'on
avait tous enfin en tout cas pour moi
dans nos générations donc ça c'est très
important si on veut pas voir non plus
un influx d'étudiants partir par exemple
au Québec comme c'est souvent le cas
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour vous la priorité numéro 1
pour résoudre enfin je sais pas la la
priorité numéro 1 mais c'est déjà enin
euh la différence enfin juste pour
revenir parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant la différence entre
justement les pays scandinaves ou les
pays d'Europe du Sud c'est dans les
politiques publiques c'est que pour le
faire à grand trait les les pays
scandinaves considèrent les étudiants
comme des jeunes adultes alors que les
pays du Sud considère les étudiants
comme des grands enfants et et en fait
il y a pas le
même ça veut dire qu'on on on on on
norganise pas euh justement leur et
d'ailleurs dans les pays scandinaves ils
partent de chez eux beaucoup plus tôt h
parce qu' il monte en autonomie beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus facilement mais il y
a des marchés locatifs très importants
alors que dans les pays du Sud on est
propriétaire donc c'est encore une fois
la question est-ce qu'on va favoriser la
propriété qui est le symbole de la de la
en France dans les pays du Sud d'avoir
réussi ou est-ce qu'on favorise le
marché locatif et on revient sur les mêm
sujets l'émission se termine je voudrais
quand même vous donner le mot de la fin
voilà le mot de la fin Antoine vous sur
quel serait aujourd'hui la priorité bah
nous au niveau de l'association de la
brigade assotive interlocataire c'est
vrai qu'on se focuse principalement sur
l'encadrement des loyers et donc on
invite vraiment tous les locataires les
jeunes locataires des grandes métropoes
à vérifier dans leur contrat de location
si le montant respecte à ne pas hésiter
exact à à nous contacter c'est des
procédures qui sont efficaces rapides et
en moyenne il y a vous êes on est
bénévole en plus on fait ça gratuitement
évidemment et c'est une moyenne de 2000
€ de récupérer à peu près C dossier et
bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci aussi à Didier Rambo qui était
avec nous en visio sur cette dernière
partie c'est la fin de cette émission un
20 ans consacré au logement se retrouve
le mois prochain pour un nouveau numéro
d'avoir 20
[Musique]
ans